The Hobbit
the Battle of the five armies not there
and back again this is the final
installment in The Hobbit trilogy where
we get to see everything come to a head
in a gigantic battle tons of characters
are flying all over the place the
characters arcs are happening everywhere
tie-ins to Laura the Rings are happening
everywhere people are getting sliced and
decapitated there's swords there's rings
there's Arkenstone there's dragon
there's fire a whole bunch of stuff and
it's pretty freaking cool I'm a big lord
of the Rings fan I love the original
trilogy I love the books by JRR Tolkien
himself I grew up with the Hobbit
cartoon from the 70s what I love about
this movie is that you're just in it
it's just boom you're in this world
there's not much set up if you haven't
watched s elation of Smaug release
recently there is some catching up to do
but you can tell that it's really
perfect for a marathon viewing because
not only does it type very well into the
last two films but it ties very nicely
with the beginning of the Lord of the
Rings all in all I really enjoyed this
movie it is the shortest Hobbit film so
far it's actually normal epic movie
length it's like 2 hours and 24 minutes
and it's funny because I actually want
to end it I was like oh ok it's over
that was actually kind of short I'm not
used to a Hobbit movie being normal like
that
no I saw the movie in 3d but not in high
frame rate and I'm glad I didn't because
I wasn't really a fan of it when I saw
the first film in high frame rate I
didn't see Smaug or this one to me it
just looks better the special effects
are not as noticeable as they were when
I saw it in 48 frames per second they
really stood out in that it look like a
cartoon there is a ton of action in this
movie it does feel like Return of the
King at times where bodies are just
flying everywhere heads are rolling all
over the place it's long it's epic and
Peter Jackson is excellent at directing
action so that's awesome but the things
that stand out to me the most in this
movie are the tiny nuances that
Jackson's so effortlessly puts in some
of his characters most noteworthy is a
relationship between Bilbo and Thorin
these guys are very complicated
Bilbo has the Arkenstone he's hiding it
Thorin really wants it and it's starting
to drive him mad
almost like Gollum towards the ring and
Bilbo watching this and some of their
conversations create some of the most
interesting moments in the movie and
that's one of the things I really liked
about this movie is it's not just a big
epic action movie some of the smaller
moments with the characters are really
well done so has the Lord of the Rings
fan I like Peter
Jackson's vision of this movie I love
the epic action I love seeing Gandalf
and Legolas back even the whole oculus
isn't in The Hobbit book I like a lot of
stuff going on the romance again just
like in Smaug is very stilted feels
tapped on and unnecessary some of the
attempts at higher drama fall flat
completely where this movie succeeds is
amazing battle sequences really awesome
characters a very cool opening scene and
some really well-done smaller moments
between characters like Bilbo and Thorin
also Luke Evans is really good in this
movie I like him a lot as his character
Gandalf we're gonna say Sir Ian McKellen
of course you're gonna know he's awesome
he knocks it out of the park there are
some Devin fanservice moments in this
movie that are not in The Hobbit book
where fans will be like okay cool nice
to see that guy I don't know really know
why he's there but it's kind of cool to
see him I guess okay bye bye you left
okay you're in one scene okay well nice
to see a man nice to see you are you
gonna come back and you're not gonna
come back you have any real purpose to
be in this movie no you don't okay well
you know it's kind of cool to see you
though I got the see yeah yeah and
that's a good segue into my other point
Tolkien purists people who really love
the books are gonna be disappointed by a
lot of things I saw this movie with a
friend of mine who's a big big big Lord
of the Rings fan he hated it like that
when it ended he was like I want to kill
someone and that's because so much of
this movie really is not like the book
at all and most people knew that going
in there's tons of added characters
there is just a whole bunch of expanded
stuff to really stretch one book in the
three movies and you're gonna have to
deal with that I think for me what I
think a film makers goal should be when
he adapts a comic book or a novel or any
other source material is that you
capture the tone and feel of that source
material not that you meticulously
recreate every small minut detail of
said source material I think that's
unnecessary I think if a filmmaker can
capture the tone and the feel of that
source material then he has succeeded
and I think that Peter Jackson's vision
of middle-earth is as good as a vision
of middle-earth as we will ever see it
actually feels like a place that we
could go to and that's big praise for a
filmmaker so Bilbo and Thorin are
fantastic the action sequences are
mind-blowing there's a lot of it it's
very fast-paced although there is a
slight rushed feeling to it all when it
ends you're kind of like
okay well it's over that was fun I feel
like it's a great companion piece for
the Lord of the Rings and I feel like it
ties everything together well some of
the drama as I said doesn't really work
and the romance is just who cares all in
all I'm gonna give the Hobbit the Battle
of the five armies a b-plus I think it's
a really awesome movie has a lot of
great sequences in there but it does
feel a little bit rushed and as I said
the romance and some of the drama really
doesn't hit home and there's a lot of
added stuff that does kind of feel like
fanservice filler I'm excited to hear
what you think of The Hobbit if you do
see it also if you didn't get a chance
to check out my review for Super Smash
Brothers for the Wii U in that review I
actually have a match between myself and
my good buddy Jake Baldino because video
games and pretty much it so if you want
to see us just talk about random stuff
while we kick each other's butts in
Super Smash go check out that review on
my channel also stay tuned in the next
couple of days because I'm gonna have a
review for a very very obscure anime I
guarantee you won't be able to guess it
you will not guess this anime review
it's so small it's so obscure but I'm
doing it because you guys have sent me a
lot of requests for smaller more
independent reviews and especially with
anime things that aren't as mainstream
doing it for you guys guys thank you so
much as always for watching and if you
did like this you can click right here
and get steppen eyes